[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 19
avril un premier trophée pour l'équipe
de france ce week-end les jeunes de
déclic théâtre ont remporté la troisième
édition du mondial d'improvisation
juniors 3 pièces et six nominations 3
création coproduite par le théâtre
montansier de versailles ont été nommé
aux molières est les césars du théâtre
et franqueville est le président de
l'ombre d'un cours à jouer en josas nous
présentera en détail la 8e édition du
festival cette année 26 mètres courts
métrages sont en lice
la troisième édition était donc est la
bonne la france elle est devenue ce
week-end championne du monde juniors
d'improvisation face à elles trois
autres pays la suisse la belgique et le
canada qui était représenté par les
québécois les français qui sont tous
membres de l'équipe junior de déclic
théâtre affrontés en finale ce dimanche
la délégation québécoise
retour sur ce dernier match avec les
images les images du berger
[Musique]
ils inscrivent leur nom au palmarès
victoire de justesse pour les français
en face les québécois n'ont rien lâché
la france l'emporté 7 à 6 annoncera sa
les grands tout c'est pour toi ya un
grand vide la danseuse de la falaise de
la terreur en serons là victor a pas
tellement d'importance ce qui compte
alors ce qui compte je pense c'est
surtout s'amuser on peut dire qu'on a
réussi un mondial un match quand on
s'est amusé je pense que il n'ya pas de
gens qui peuvent dire qu'ils ont réussi
blanc match on s'étend pas amusé après
quatre jours de compétition l'équipe de
france vient de remporter le 3e mondial
d'improvisation juniors face à elle le
québec la belgique et la suisse de jouer
à l'étranger effectivement ça change
tout simplement parce qu'on se rencontre
avec d'autres équipes qui finalement
même si on a une même langue il ya des
styles de jeu qui sont différents et
c'est surtout ça qui est intéressant je
trouve dans un tournoi à l'étranger
c'est de se confronter pas seulement à
une improvisation anthem à des
personnages mais à une autre manière de
jouer de parler même parfois
je crois que c'est plié à tronche
langage
dragons ordre après l'assassinât des
juifs et à la france ils recevoir
derrière la logistique l'équipe ii dès
qu'ils perdent
ça fait super bien passé franchement
c'était trop cool il ya eu de grands
moments de fête des grands moments de de
plaisir de partage de de fun du jeu il
ya eu de l'impro enfin je sais pas
comment je peux le définir mais si je
dois essayer de résumer ce qui s'est
passé ça a été vraiment un vrai
carrefour de la culture de
l'improvisation théâtrale en fête et du
match d'improvisation parce que chacun
est venu avec un petit peu ses manières
de faire et où ils sont adaptés à ce
qu'on nous propose à trappes prochaine
édition la quatrième ce sera au québec
un tournoi itinérant cette fois un
spectacle à découvrir ce week-end cette
fois les spectateurs sont invités à la
ferme des animaux lors d'une révolte les
animaux chasse les fermiers pour créer
leur république
le classique de l'écrivain britannique
george orwell retrace l'arrivée de
staline au pouvoir l'oeuvre est revisité
par la compagnie in cauda et la jeune
troupe de la ferme de bel ébat écouter
godefroy ségal le metteur en scène était
au micro de camille lambert
c'est encore un texte qui utilisent
effectivement un esprit un petit peu
compte quelque chose d'assez universel
puisque la transposition à chaque fois
sur sur les animaux pour parler des
hommes fait du coup tout le monde
comprend que c'est une adresse vraiment
général quoi pour tous tous les êtres
vivants de la planète
six nominations aux molière pour trois
spectacles c'est la belle nouvelle qu'a
appris le théâtre montansier de
versailles au début du mois ces trois
pièces sont des créations coproduite par
la salle versaillaise
regardez le cac schneider pourrait bien
voir pierre arditi récompensé d'un
molière du comédien
la pièce a été coproduite par le théâtre
montansier de versailles deux autres
créations sont nommés les femmes
savantes et réparer les vivants c'est
une satisfaction pour nous parce que
c'est des spectacles que nous avons
accompagné coproduit et qui sont en plus
on va dire le reflet exact de ce que
nous faisons ce projet c'est
d'accompagner des artistes dans leur
processus de création de les accompagner
on va dire en écoute en finance
quelquefois en répétition en temps de
plateau
de les aider en termes de communication
afin de vraiment de les porter sur sur
ce qu'est la jeunesse d'un spectacle sa
préparation ses répétitions et ensuite
son exploitation
le théâtre c'est environ 2 millions
d'euros de budget par saison la moitié
destinée à la création une douzaine est
co produite chaque année le terreau
content c'est d'abord un lieu de
création et ensuite un lieu d'accueil
mais dans la programmation telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui
depuis
notre arrivée c'est à dire la saison 13
14 il ya d'abord deux tiers de
coproduction et un tiers on va dire
d'accueil de spectacles que nous avons
vu et que nous choisissons de programmé
au théâtre montansier un seul en scène
un classique un drame et six nominations
la 29e nuit des molières c'est le 29 mai
prochain
le coup de coeur de cette semaine c'est
celui de cyril haddad de l'espace
philippe noiret aux clayes-sous-bois
écouter cette semaine notre coup de
coeur et le film une vie ailleurs
réalisé par olivier peyon avec isabelle
carré et ramzy bedia c'est en uruguay
que si lui retrouve enfin la trace de
son fils enlevé il ya quatre ans par son
ex mari avec l'aide précieuse de mehdi
el par le récupérer mais arrivé là bas
rien ne se passe comme prévu
l'enfant élevé par sa grand mère et sa
tante semble heureux et épanoui sylvie
réalise alors que felipe a grandi sans
aide et que sa vie est désormais
ailleurs sur le schéma d'un fait divers
à forte tendance mélodramatique ce film
inspiré d'une histoire vraie sonne juste
à l'image de son interprétation il
emporte le spectateur à travers un
voyage existentiel où une mer se remet
en question fassent au bonheur ce que
son enfant a bâti sans elles et avec
d'autres le film pose des questions
essentielles sur la filiation et la
famille entre fragilité et impulsivité
isabelle carré joue le rôle d'une
magnifique mer en apprentissage quant à
ramzy bedia il s'en sort avec les
honneurs dans ce rôle inhabituel
son interprétation est à la fois
sensible et subtile avec douceur et
pudeur
la mise en scène s'attache à chaque
détail du quotidien de ce petit garçon
vous avez un petit garçon formidable
mais c'est pas possible un ruisseau lui
faire du mal
foutez moi
j'obtiens micro
une vie ailleurs est à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
cinéma toujours le week-end prochain ce
sera la huitième édition du festival
international du film court de jouer en
josas une trentaine de films va être
projeté pendant ces deux jours on écoute
franceville est lé président du festival
il nous en dit un peu plus franck bullet
bonjour je vous êtes le président et
organisateur du festival l'ombre d'un
cours qui se tiendra les 21 et 22 avril
prochain alors c'est la huitième édition
déjà
quel est le programme alors le programme
est assez chargé alors bien sûr une
compétition de courts métrages comme
d'habitude compétition officielle et
compétition jeune public le jeune public
qui a lieu le samedi après midi de 14
heures à 17 heures et avec 13 films
d'animation et de fiction et puis donc
des films 23 23 à 26 films en
compétition avec des récompenses à la
clé et un jury de professionnels qui qui
sera là pour pour décerner des prix et
donc en huit éditions toujours cet amour
du court métrage toujours toujours on
continue on est toujours passionnés ont
chaque année on découvre vraiment
en plus des films toujours aussi bien
toujours si novateur on essaie de
dénicher la perle rare et on est
toujours agréablement surpris y est
toujours contente de le faire la
particularité de ce festival c'est
surtout la rencontre des professionnels
et du public c'est ça qui vous motive
depuis huit éditions voilà on essaie de
ne pas faire que de la projection c'est
aussi un festival sert aussi à faire des
rencontres notamment pour les
professionnels et les jeunes
réalisateurs qui présentent leurs films
c'est de rencontrer d'abord le public et
bien sûr de voir comment le film à être
accueillis et puis aussi des
professionnels dans le cadre justement
de de constituer un jury
ils sont là aussi pour donner leur avis
et faire la faire évoluer aussi à la
carrière ou des réalisateurs
merci franck il est alors pour découvrir
les réalisateurs en devenir et tous ces
films courts métrages en compétition
rendez vous les 21 et 22 avril prochain
au théâtre du vieux marché de jouy en
josas
et on débute l'agenda avec de la danse
les rois de la piste vont enflammer la
scène du prisme à elancourt vont une
rôtissoire humour grinçant et bande-son
adeline emblématique de plusieurs
décennies de musique et un tarif de
dernière minute est proposé un rendez
vous musical à présent emmanuel
rossfelder sera sur la scène de l'espace
albert camus de maurepas surnommé le
magicien de la guitare il proposera un
récital vendredi 21 avril on regarde un
extrait
[Musique]
moment
on retourne aux prises mais pour un
concert de jazz cette fois emilie et
doubs propose un répertoire de standards
de jazz
vous pourrez y entendre des reprises
d'aretha franklin otis redding ou encore
un rite charles et c'est leur dernier
concert de la saison ce samedi les sauts
et les solistes de lavilledieu vous
invite dans l'atmosphère d'un salon
romantique françois dumont interprétera
notamment quatre ballades de chopin et
on termine avec un spectacle pour les
plus jeunes et c'est du cirque musical
une pianiste un acrobate
ils sont dans un carrousel comme une
boîte de musique c'est un moment
poétique à vivre en famille ce mardi 25
avril regarder
[Musique]
oh
e
le service culture est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]